[Música]
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález la situación
en la frontera entre méxico y eeuu es
crítica el alto flujo de inmigrantes la
pandemia de kobe 19 la falta de
infraestructura entre otra infinidad de
factores han generado un desafío a la
administración del presidente joe biden
que todavía no ha calificado esta
situación como una crisis pero las fotos
publicadas por el representante
demócrata henry cuellar del estado de
texas evidencian la magnitud del
hacinamiento en las instalaciones
fronterizas decenas de niños también
adultos en el piso allí simplemente a la
espera de alguna decisión por parte de
las autoridades migratorias y están allí
en precarias condiciones y en medio de
la amenaza de la pandemia del cobi 19
así es como están las cosas veamos
sobre balsas ilegales como esta maniobra
das por contrabandistas cientos de
migrantes centroamericanos intentan
cruzar el río grande buscan llegar a
suelo estadounidense en el tramo
conocido como romá en texas
los que tienen suerte lo logran pero los
que no se entregan a las autoridades
como ellos que agotados y con sus
pequeños a cuestas se dieron al hambre y
el frío
tras rendirse son trasladados a refugios
como este en donde el mer maldonado un
solicitante de asilo hondureño de 40
años recuerda cómo intentó atravesar la
frontera con su hijo isaac él se motivó
y así cosas el viene bien motivado
cuando mira cosas tan bonitas al día y
desde cuando escucharon ruidos tan
fuerte le da miedito solo en la última
jornada al menos 30 hondureños como
elmer fueron guiados por un alguacil
para entregarse a la patrulla fronteriza
pero la situación más crítica la
afrontan los menores no acompañados a
medida que siguen pasando desde méjico
los centros de atención empiezan a
llegar a su capacidad máxima en medio de
esta crisis que la administración de
darden le achaca al pasado gobierno
el presidente trump separó a más de
3.000 niños de sus padres y en 2019
tuvimos el mayor aumento en décadas así
que hay muchas razones por la que los
niños deciden emigrar estamos enviando
un mensaje muy claro la gente debe
quedarse en sus regiones
mientras localizan a sus familias a
algunos de los jóvenes que permanecen en
este albergue de carrizos prince
intentan refugiarse en el fútbol y así
olvidar por momentos la violencia y la
pobreza que los llevó a mirar
ahora demos un vistazo a las cifras sean
de acuerdo con la oficina de aduanas y
protección fronteriza en febrero del
más de 97 mil migrantes cruzaron la
frontera de manera irregular 60.000 de
ellos eran adultos solteros o personas
solas mientras que 32 mil eran familias
pero lo que más le preocupa a la
comunidad internacional y también a
varios organismos internacionales son
esos menores de edad ese alto flujo de
menores de edad que está intentando
cruzar la frontera son los sin sus
padres para febrero del 2021 de acuerdo
con cifras de la oficina de aduana y
protección fronteriza más de 9.200
algunos medios citan más de 9.400
menores de edad no acompañados fueron
detenidos por la patrulla fronteriza y
están bajo custodia del gobierno de eeuu
como les decía a la administración del
presidente by de la situación todavía no
la considera como una crisis es sólo una
coyuntura de gran importancia que debe
ser abordada con toda la seriedad y por
eso han enfocado varios esfuerzos estas
fueron las palabras del presidente
la verdad es que nada ha cambiado es
maniquí como mucha gente ha venido
aumentó en 28 por ciento los niños en la
frontera en mi administración
31 por ciento en el último año en 2019
antes de la pandemia de la
administración trump el trump en el 6 y
el chapín er y sucede siempre cada año
y si hay un aumento significativo en el
número de personas que llegan a la
frontera en los meses de invierno de
enero febrero y marzo
march y que pasa del otro lado de la
frontera
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador pidió hacer un trabajo en
conjunto entre los dos países el
mandatario mexicano también indicó que
hay que hacer frente a la migración
desde el origen y eso pasa entonces por
el desarrollo económico de países que
son parte del triángulo del norte como
guatemala honduras y el salvador esto
fue lo que dijeron allí en la capital
mexicana
la gente no se va a eeuu por gusto se va
por necesidad
entonces se tiene que apoyar al
desarrollo de centroamérica
y el sur de méxico para analizar este
tema hemos invitado a maría herrera ya
está en la ciudad de miami en el estado
de florida es estratega republicana
doctora en ciencias jurídicas abogada
especializada en temas migratorios el
vice presidenta de la asamblea hispana
del partido republicano en ese estado
del sur de la unión americana y en la
ciudad de washington está a benjamín
quedan él es el director adjunto del
programa latinoamericano woodrow wilson
international center for scholars les
recuerdo que ustedes también hacen parte
de esta conversación pueden dejar todas
sus preguntas y sus comentarios a través
de las redes sociales estamos en
facebook y también no se encuentran en
instagram y en twitter como france24
s santi logo también que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta es numeral el
debate efe 24 tenemos publicado una
encuesta para que ustedes dejen allí sus
opiniones están en todas las redes
sociales del canal cree que la política
migratoria planteada por la
administración de joe biden podrá
mejorar las condiciones de los migrantes
en la frontera esperamos todos sus
comentarios allí están las
paola del equipo de redes sociales de
france 24 muy atentas a los comentarios
que ustedes dejen allí pues quiero
comenzar entonces preguntándole a
natalia amarilla perdón nuestra nuestra
primera invitada allí en la ciudad de
miami y preguntándole por la gran
pregunta que se está haciendo en eeuu y
también la comunidad internacional la
situación en la frontera entre méxico de
eeuu es una crisis para la
administración baiden o es simplemente
un momento coyuntural como lo han
denominado allí en la casa blanca
es una crisis una crisis humanitaria la
peor que hemos tenido en las dos últimas
décadas es una crisis además muy
politizada consecuencia del efecto
llamada es decir que este presidente y
la vicepresidente durante meses han
dicho que iban a levantar el programa de
protección del inmigrante en méxico y
además iban a eliminar esos acuerdos con
el salvador honduras y nicaragua para
que los inmigrantes que huyen o que
quieran pedir asilo lo hagan en el
primer país seguro al que llega
efectivamente la administración de
donald trump intentó llegar a acuerdos y
además dota presupuestariamente vio
mucho dinero también a centroamérica
para que precisamente la fuerza del
cuerpo de seguridad ayudase a mantener
una entrada legal y ordenada del digamos
de estos inmigrantes que llegaban a
veces con familias comunidades
familiares a veces como menores como
vosotros de 100 menores no acompañados
es lastimosamente la realidad que
vivimos ahora mismo el secretario de
seguridad nacional
mallorca ha cometido un grave error
diciendo que vamos a dejar entrar a
todos los menores no acompañados porque
eso lo único que hace es intensificar el
tráfico de menores y eso da una llamada
muy clara a los coyotes y a las mafias
de traficantes de seres humanos es que
los niños pueden venir a este país que
van a ser acoja y acogido y muchísimas
familias van a mandar a los menores a
los eeuu el 'efecto llamada' y el tema
de la seguridad de estos grupos de
tráfico de personas que de acuerdo a
mariah pues podrían aumentar su labor
allí y su presencia en la frontera con
estos menores no acompañados
benjamín en la ciudad de washington su
opinión estamos en una crisis
humanitaria migratoria una crisis
fronteriza o esto simplemente es una
coyuntura y un momento pico de personas
que llegan a la frontera como lo han
dicho allí en washington como lo decía
hoy el presidente by the end en su
primera rueda de prensa
tiene la zona el presidente y bailén
este es un gran desafío pero pasa varias
veces en la historia reciente de nuestro
país y de la frontera la crisis está en
américa central donde las condiciones
son tan difíciles que tantas personas
están saliendo de sus pueblos de sus
casas para hacer un viaje tan peligroso
y para llegar con mucha incertidumbre en
la frontera con los estados unidos es un
gran desafío no se puede negar y
necesitamos más recursos humanitarios en
la frontera para poder procesar a los
migrantes que están llegando es así que
que están llegando con más esperanza
porque ahora estamos cumpliendo con los
requisitos que nuestras leyes también
estamos cumpliendo con las obligaciones
nuestras según los tratados
internacionales que hemos firmado y es
así que no queremos continuar con las
políticas migratorias desde el
presidente de trump quien no le
interesaba las condiciones en
centroamérica
las condiciones en la frontera solo
quería el causar de ser a la frontera y
de sacar a todos los migrantes legales e
ilegales del país el efecto del cambio
de las políticas es en alguna forma un
incentivo para los migrantes para que
para que lleguen reconozco esto y por
eso digo que es un gran desafío de
comunicación y de recursos que
necesitamos invertir en el sistema
migratorio en la frontera pero repito lo
más importante es reconocer que la
crisis está en américa central no en la
frontera nuestra
mariah ya le doy la palabra usted quiero
tocar un punto que benjamín destacó hoy
es la respuesta que está dando el
gobierno del presidente vaivén pero
analizando un poco lo que están haciendo
y analizando y usted entrará en detalle
en la respuesta que está dando
washington es muy similar a lo que
estaba trabajando si allí en la frontera
durante el último año en la
administración de donald trump a
básicamente la única diferencia son
estos niños migrantes no acompañados que
están siendo acogidos aquí en eeuu y que
pues no están siendo expulsados como si
sucedía durante la administración trompa
pero básicamente los procedimientos son
iguales no para nada ha cambiado
absolutamente todo porque con el
presidente de donald trump teníamos el
protocolo de protección del inmigrante
que permitía que las familias
permaneciesen unidas en méxico esperando
pero no detenida yo soy abogada de
inmigración y les puedo decir que
evidentemente méxico es un país
peligroso
lópez obrador se comprometió digamos a
disponer de albergues y mandar los
inmigrantes en autobuses gratuitos y
públicos a ciudades más seguras que las
ciudades fronterizas donde hay donde
campa a sus anchas el crimen organizado
pero las familias permanecían unidas
ahora mismo las familias que vienen aquí
son deportadas por otra parte los
menores indocumentados que vienen solos
es decir no acompañados se les deja
entrar y no se les pide ningún digamos
ningún tipo de requisitos esto es esto
es un drama porque estamos viendo que
por una parte esto va a tener
consecuencias enormes santiago es decir
estamos en un mes en el que
supuestamente se iba a pasar o se va a
intentar aprobar la reforma inmigratoria
pero ya no solo los republicanos sino
como vosotros decías al inicio ha sido
un demócrata el que ha filtrado las
imágenes del trato inhumano que se les
está dando a los menores porque en
centros que supuestamente sólo deberían
estar doscientos trescientos menores se
están llegando a 800/900 y pasando los
miles han dado más de 300 menores
positivos del coronavirus en muchísimo
en los centros y esto es esto es
lamentable y bueno es lo que estamos
viviendo es un tema súper sensible y
tiene muchas aristas maría pero uno de
los puntos que siempre les señalaron y
le criticarán a la administración trompo
fue haber separado algunos menores de
sus padres y haberlos tenido separados
de sus familiares qué opina usted al
respecto benjamín sobre la respuesta que
ha dado la administración byd en que
como yo explicaba y como mariah pues
complemento muy bien sobre el panorama y
en la frontera hay muchos apuntes que y
muchas
partes de esta reacción que son muy
parecidas a las que ya tenía la
administración trump no ha variado mucho
no nada que ver con el comportamiento
del presidente trump y su administración
para el presidente de trump él intentaba
de organizar una respuesta muy cruel
para que los inmigrantes que llegaron al
país sufrieron mucho y para que los
demás no quisieran llegar para el
presidente bayern es totalmente al revés
quiere invertir más recursos y lo está
haciendo ahora para que hayan
condiciones en la frontera que hay más
tranquilas que además seguras para los
niños que llegan al mismo tiempo lo más
importante es la respuesta a las causas
primarias de la crisis migratoria no lo
que qué va a distinguir a la política la
respuesta de la administración de bairén
va a ser sus inversiones en la región en
américa central por para el presidente
de trump él no tenía ningún interés en
abordar el tema de la crisis en américa
central al revés
él sacó toda la existencia exterior que
nosotros estábamos invirtiendo en la
época del presidente obama
en américa central y porque para el
presidente de trump solo lo importante
fue cerrar la frontera si es una
respuesta totalmente distinta ahora
antes de analizar el papel de méxico y
la situación en américa central
mariah que tanto se está politizando
este tema migratorio porque vemos a los
republicanos que han recurrido a este
tema de la migración como una principal
línea de ataque constante contra la
administración baiden y también vemos a
los demócratas que se escudan en que la
situación está así por lo que dejó la
administración anterior este rifirrafe
choca las posiciones choca a la
administración a las diferentes cámaras
en el congreso pero se necesitan son
soluciones no es momento de hacer de
pronto un pacto de llegar a acuerdos
para poder solucionar este tema
definitivamente lo que pasa que mientras
la seguridad la frontera se torna un
tema de seguridad nacional y a la vez es
un tema federal por lo tanto solo el
gobierno federal la cámara de
representante en washington y el senado
tienen digamos capacidad para legislar y
para llegar a consensos pues vamos a
mantener digamos este impase volviendo
al tema que comentaba y compañero esto
no sólo se trata de una crisis en
centroamérica yo represento a exiliados
políticos exiliados políticos que vienen
desde cuba desde venezuela es decir el
problema de iberoamérica son
precisamente la falta de libertad
económica las dictaduras los regímenes
totalitarios y recordemos que por esa
frontera también se han arrestado a ocho
posibles terroristas o incluso a
personas que han cometido
digamos delito de carácter sexual ya
condenados aquí
santiago no va a haber un acuerdo
mientras los demócratas no se
complementan con la seguridad fronteriza
tenemos una vicepresidente que ahora ha
sido designada para resolver la crisis
en la frontera que llegó a
y dar a las agencias que se encargan del
cumplimiento de la ley de inmigración
como el ku klux klan los demócratas no
hacen absolutamente nada para detener el
flujo en la entrada desordenada de
inmigrantes y por cierto volviendo al
punto anterior que dijo mi compañero es
absolutamente falso que donald trans no
invirtiese no solo en centroamérica sino
en el sur de méxico por eso esos países
en centroamericanos en centroamérica se
comprometieron a utilizar su fuerza y
cuerpos de seguridad del estado para
detener la inmigración ilegal eso es la
clave ahora no se puede enviar como ha
prometido esta administración 4000
millones de dólares a centroamérica y
destinarla a ongs de extrema izquierda
cuyo único objetivo es digamos dinamitar
el estado de derecho en centroamérica yo
trabajo con muchas por muchos compañeros
en centroamérica nos dicen la solución
para la detención de la inmigración
ilegal es el desarrollo económico pero
el dinero tiene que ir al pueblo
hondureño nicaragüense y salvadoreño no
puede ir ni a ong ni a políticos
corruptos esa es la solución
qué piensa usted es benjamín allí en la
ciudad de washington y entramos ya en en
este tema de el triángulo del norte la
situación que se vive allí en
centroamérica y el papel de méxico
es un hecho claro que el presidente de
trump suspendió la existencia al
triángulo de norte al final él tomó la
decisión de invertir al algo allá solo
para la fuerza su seguridad cuando los
gobiernos de américa central dijeron que
si estaban dispuesto a detener a los
migrantes en condiciones muy peligrosas
en vez de dejarlos pasar para llegar a
la frontera con los estados unidos pero
no con el fin de desarrollar la economía
ni de dar una respuesta a la crisis
humanitaria económica y política en esos
países por eso no estaba buscando el
presidente y trump una respuesta a las
causas primarias de la crisis migratoria
sino de intentar de de frenar los flujos
de inmigrantes solamente a través de
inversiones en las fuerzas de seguridad
igualmente no logró nada porque en
noviembre y diciembre pasado llegaron
más que
de 70.000 personas en la frontera
nuestra que es una clara señal que las
políticas migratorias de la antigua
administración no funcionaron ahora
tenemos que dar tiempo algunos meses más
que un año para la deuda de migración
para reiniciar todos los esfuerzos
antiguos en américa central para que
haya esperanza para que haya
oportunidades para que haya más
seguridad para que haya políticos menos
corruptos para que nosotros tengamos la
capacidad de dar una respuesta a esos
desafíos enormes en esta región bueno
también es que hay que decir que la
coyuntura es muy particular sobre todo
este año porque venimos de estar
prácticamente un año en confinamiento en
todo el continente por el tema de la
pandemia de kobe 19 y también después
del paso de dos huracanes muy fuertes
que afectaron seriamente a nicaragua
honduras y guatemala y en cierta medida
también al salvador entonces son
circunstancias particulares que se suman
a este panorama
qué hacer entonces con ese triángulo del
norte benjamín a gol a la ronda la
inversa que hacer entonces con guatemala
con honduras con el salvador y con
nicaragua en países con economías
pequeñas fuertes inestables
políticamente pero esto no es una
novedad así han sido a lo largo de
muchas décadas y los gobiernos de eeuu
ya han invertido han enviado fuerzas
militares en su momento colaboraron en
los conflictos internos se han salido
han intentado darles facilidades para el
comercio y nada funciona que lo que pasa
allí
reconozco que los desafíos hay enorme
así que lleva muchas décadas sufriendo
de esas condiciones difíciles pero a mi
juicio no hemos hecho un esfuerzo con
los recursos suficientes ni con
esfuerzos consistentes para realmente
dar una respuesta a esos desafíos no son
nada fácil resolver los temas que acabas
de mencionar pero hay la posibilidad a
la posibilidad de desarrollar la
economía de generar más puestos de
trabajo de dar capacidad y de capacitar
a las fuerzas de seguridad para luchar
contra la corrupción en la región que es
algo que un esfuerzo que suspendió
también el presidente de trump
cuando si sigue en guatemala una unidad
de las naciones unidas y algo parecido a
honduras salieron de los de ambos países
porque eeuu dejó de apoyar o de insistir
que que quieren para combatir la
corrupción en esos dos países es difícil
porque los gobiernos en estos tres
países no son socios ideales para los
eeuu el presidente hondureño es una
picante según la información que maneja
el departamento de justicia en guatemala
el gobierno no está muy comprometido con
la lucha contra la corrupción en el
salvador tenemos un presidente muy
popular pero que no respeta al peso y
contrapeso en su sistema democrático
pues pero al menos hay una sociedad
civil en cada país que está dispuesto a
colaborar con los eeuu en esos esfuerzos
pero son esfuerzos de largo plazo y
tenemos que que dejar a la
administración para desarrollar un
programa para asistir a esos países en
estos momentos tan complicados
mariah qué hacer con esos países del
triángulo del norte como ya lo hemos
mencionado esto no es no es nuevo la
situación allí y los esfuerzos de la
comunidad internacional han sido varios
y a lo largo de las décadas
de nuevo yo vuelvo a repetir que esta
entrada masiva y desordenada de
inmigrantes no sólo se debe a los
digamos a las condiciones que se dan en
centroamérica entran por la frontera sur
de los eeuu inmigrantes de más de 150
nacionalidades lo primero que hay que
hacer es dejar de hacer negocios y dejar
de anunciar a bombo y platillo que vamos
a digamos a levantar embargos con narco
dictaduras como la cubana también por
supuesto mantener las sanciones con
venezuela con respecto al caso de
guatemala así que nombra mi compañero es
un auténtico fracaso y digamos que ha
sido escandaloso la gestión que hacen
las naciones unidas- de esa comisión y
pueden entrevistar a colegas que están
trabajando en guatemala porque en cuanto
se produzcan las naciones unidas ya
sabemos lo que tenemos es con la
supuesta política de desarrollo vienen
las políticas de materia de género más
aborto más feminismo extremo y todo lo
que conlleva el globalismo que está
demostrado que no está haciendo nada más
que
acarrea conflictos y confrontamiento en
la sociedad civil por otra parte en
cuanto al salvador y nicaragua de nuevo
en nicaragua las sanciones tienen que
mantenerse y tenemos que llegar a una
solución real y por supuesto yo creo que
el enfoque de donald tran era el
acertado porque porque no se puede
entregar más fondos a esos a esos países
centroamericanos como tú dices santiago
a fondo perdido y como reconocía el
compañero en noviembre y diciembre
llegaron de nuevo muchísimos miles de
inmigrantes la frontera porque porque
estaban a la expectativa de que yo va a
ir en accediese al poder entonces
yo creo en la solución está clara si
tenemos una oficina como acnur que
debería de actuar tiene que actuar para
dar apoyo a los refugiados y el asilo y
el refugio tiene que pedirse o bien en
sus países o bien en el primer país
seguro hay que trabajar a nivel regional
y desde luego la frontera segura en la
solución y no crear un efecto llamado
mar y hablemos del papel que tiene
méxico en toda esta historia a lo largo
de esta semana vimos esa reunión de alto
nivel de funcionarios del gobierno
todos unidos visitaron ciudad de mexico
se reunieron con delegados de la
cancillería mexicana para hablar de este
tema migratorio en mexico ya ha hecho
varias gestiones a lo largo de estos
años con la administración de lópez
obrador reforzó la frontera con
guatemala y puso a su a su nueva guardia
nacional a funcionar allí para frenar un
poco la entrada de los migrantes al
territorio mexicano cómo está el papel
de mexico allí es insuficiente o méxico
lo está politizando está usándolo como
una carta de negociación con la
administración en washington para
recibir entre otras cosas hasta vacunas
por ejemplo
definitivamente o sea lo que es
lamentable es escuchar ahora lópez
obrador diciendo qué bueno que eeuu y la
administración by después que ha elevado
las expectativas de los inmigrantes y
por supuesto que tiene razón pero méxico
ha sido el primer país que cuando él
llegó y accedió al poder dijo que los
inmigrantes iban a poder entrar a méxico
que van a estar protegidos que se le iba
a dar trabajo que se iba a dar unas
protecciones sociales y eso es
absolutamente falso yo trabajo en mexico
en una universidad y también he dado
clase a la judicatura y conozco muy bien
el marco jurídico mexicano y méxico es
uno de los países que peor trato a los
inmigrantes pero no por nada sino porque
primero no tenía un marco regulador en
materia de protección de los derechos
humanos en segundo es un país
extremadamente peligroso y en tercer
lugar la fuerza y cuerpos de seguridad
la judicatura la policía y la fiscalía
no están preparados para digamos ofrecer
esa seguridad jurídica
y bueno es lo que tenemos ahora mismo yo
creo que lópez obrador debería de
colaborar con job hay de como sí lo hizo
con donald trump pero lo que hemos visto
ha sido justo lo contrario es decir que
cuando yo vaya y le ha pedido que acepte
a esos inmigrantes que son devueltos a
méxico por primera vez desde bueno desde
que yo tengo uso de razón ha pasado una
ley diciendo que se niega a recibir a
los inmigrantes que se han devuelto por
eeuu por lo tanto la situación es muy
delicada y volviendo al punto inicial de
necesitamos un presidente que ponga
orden orden en la región y que diga sí
señora usted tienen que cumplir también
con los tratados internacionales como
decía mi compañero hay tratados
internacionales hay tratados de
refugiado y hay tratado de protección de
menores
benjamín su opinión sobre el papel que
tiene méxico en esta situación
bueno va a ser un poco más complicado
coordinar con la administración de lópez
obrador porque ahora la administración
en la casa blanca no está dispuesto a
siempre a estar manejando a nuestros
vecinos allá con la ruptura de acuerdos
de libre comercio o con una empresa
cerrar la frontera ahora estamos re
estableciendo una relación con respecto
y bueno con una agenda más amplia que la
agenda migratoria pero creo que es así
que el presidente de médico está
comprometido con el trato con el trato
humanitario de los migrantes que están
llegando a su país y quiere coordinar
con los eeuu en el manejo de la crisis
lo difícil es que méxico no tiene los
recursos necesarios para poder invertir
en américa central en el triángulo del
norte dice siempre al presidente
mexicano que tenemos que dar una
respuesta fuerte con muchos recursos y
es así y es necesario pero sería bueno
si méxico también
era algo para contribuir al esfuerzo en
el criado del norte y dice siempre el
que necesitamos una respuesta como de
marshall puedan para américa central y
repito creo que él tiene razón lo
necesario ahora es trabajar en conjunto
para dar una respuesta para dar
oportunidades económicas para los
viajantes del triángulo del norte pero
pero que recién en méxico
a cambio vende también porque además
recordemos que este país está en año de
elecciones legislativas y los partidos
necesitan dar efectividad y dar muestras
de lograr cometidos y que están
trabajando que recibe méxico entonces en
esta negociación con eeuu aunque recibía
cambio
bueno somos socios cuando estamos
trabajando juntos hay beneficios para
los dos lados las economías están muy
conectadas hay temas de seguridad que
afectan a los dos países y no solamente
el tema migratorio que fue el único tema
bilateral durante la administración del
presidente trump tenemos nosotros
también la oportunidad de dar una
respuesta a la crisis sanitaria por
ejemplo el médico acabas de mencionar la
decisión de la utilización
estadounidense de ofrecer vacunas al
pueblo mexicano hay hay muchas cosas que
podemos hacer trabajando como una unidad
en el canadá eeuu y méxico y lo
importante también es controlar el virus
para poder abrir la frontera para el
flujo de negocios y de inmigrantes y no
sé de gente que trabajan en otros lados
de la frontera
mariah para el cierre del programa la
conclusión de toda esta situación que va
a suceder en que va a terminar esta
historia esto le pasará factura al
presidente de byd en y se desarrollará
aquí una verdadera crisis o esto
mitigará con la llegada del verano
yo estoy completamente seguro que esto
le va a pasar factura en el 2022 cuando
tenemos más eleccions porque hay
muchísimos demócratas que están muy
enfadados con las políticas federales y
en materia de migración que está
aplicando este esta nueva administración
yo creo también que esta semana hemos
visto cómo está migración ha tenido que
dar marcha atrás y ha anunciado no solo
que van a invertir y que están
invirtiendo miles de dólares en anuncios
en la radio en la televisión desde
brasil hasta méxico para que los
inmigrantes sepa que la frontera no es
tan abierta y por otra parte van a tener
que cerrar la frontera y van a tener que
ponerse serio porque si no van a perder
las elecciones en el 2022 y benjamín su
opiniones para la conclusión del cierre
del programa
creo que vamos a poder resolver la
crisis o el desafío en la frontera a
través de más inversión de recursos
humanos y de lugares sanitarios y
seguros para los migrantes jóvenes que
están llegando ahora pero repito lo más
importante no son los efectos para las
elecciones intermedio acá ni en méxico
sino en la responsabilidad de nuestro
pueblo de dar una respuesta a los
pueblos centroamericanos que están
sufriendo tanto de los efectos
sanitarios y económicos de cambio
climático y el de la pandemia en el eje
central este es el motivo del flujo de
personas y este es el tema más
importante para nosotros ahora pues
maría herrera en la ciudad de miami y
benjamín quedan en la ciudad de
washington en la capital de eeuu
muchas gracias por haber hecho este
análisis para nosotros y por haber
compartido con nosotros sus opiniones en
torno a este tema esta primera coyuntura
o crisis dependiendo de cómo lo quieran
analizar y ver que está enfrentando al
presidente de eeuu poco más de 60
después de haber asumido la presidencia
en la casa blanca le recuerdo que pueden
seguir dejando todos sus comentarios y
sus preguntas a través de las redes
sociales cree que la política migratoria
planteada por la administración de joe
biden podrá mejorar las condiciones de
los migrantes en la frontera es nuestra
pregunta del programa de hoy gracias a
ustedes por la sintonía sigan en france
[Música]